dans cette ville de trois millions
d'habitants
la vie reprend peu à peu son cours
depuis mercredi les transports en commun
reprennent du service
les commerces aussi le tout dans le
respect le plus strict des mesures
barrières distanciation physique ou
encore présence professionnelle limité à
50% du personnel les entreprises ont
anticipé le retour de leurs salariés
et bien après environ 70 jours c'est la
première fois où nous allons pouvoir
nous réintégrer dans la société
nous sommes tous équipés des équipements
que l'entreprise nous a donné et je
pense que cette situation va bien se
passer pour nous si une personne avec
une température élevée est détectée nous
appelons immédiatement les secours afin
que les mesures appropriées soient
prises
c'est donc toute une vie qui reprend ses
droits dans la capitale équatorienne
mais sous certaines conditions
le couvre-feu maintenant réduit à huit
heures par jour dans les restaurants de
la ville
il a fallu aussi s'adapter pour
accueillir les clients en toute sécurité
est bien la vérité est qu'au cours des
soixante dix derniers jours je pense que
tout le monde a traversé une crise au
niveau commercial
donc aujourd'hui nous avons rouvert en
prenant les mesures nécessaires pour
notre sécurité et celle de nos clients
tels que l'utilisation de vaisselle
jetable les distanciation physique la
fumigation quand les clients entrent et
l'utilisation de gels hydroalcooliques
pays parmi les plus touchés en amérique
latine par le cos vie de 19 à l'équateur
compte aujourd'hui près de quarante et
un mille cas pour plus de 3400 décès
après avoir vécu en autarcie pendant
presque trois mois le pays et sa
capitale retrouve enfin une liberté de
mouvement et ce pour le plus grand
bonheur de ses habitants